this episode of the minimalists is 100%
advertisement free if you'd like to
support the podcast visit the
minimalists comm slash donate
enjoy the show
every little thing you think that's me
every little thing you think that you
need every little thing that's just
feeding your greed you know I bet you'll
be fine hello everybody and welcome to
the minimalist podcast where we discuss
what it means to live a meaningful life
with less I'm Joshua fields Milburn and
I am Ryan Nicodemus with a little bit of
a cold today but we're still the
minimalists we are still the minimalists
I hope you feel better soon Ryan but
thank you for showing up for this
welcome to episode number 11 we're
calling this one sentimental because
we're dealing with a bunch of questions
about sentimental items so we have some
voicemail questions from social media
questions before before we get to that
let's let's talk about a few things that
Ryan I have going on we are hitting the
road in May this May 2016 for our
minimalism documentary Tour 2016 where
we're gonna answer the question how
might your life be better with less so
we're gonna be showing our documentary
in these 14 different cities New York
Boston Washington DC
Miami Dallas Dayton Chicago Seattle San
Francisco Los Angeles Salt Lake City
Missoula and Toronto Canada Toronto I
should say
Toronto Canada and so we're going to a
bunch of different cities and a few of
those events have actually quite a few
of them have already sold out and so
don't worry so we sold out in New York
we sold out in DC in Boston and Dayton
and Chicago and Seattle and San
Francisco and LA in Salt Lake City but
we added second screenings or got bigger
theaters for most of those so if you you
were on there before and you said oh I
really wanted to go to the Los Angeles
event but it's sold out well don't don't
worry we have a bigger theater there or
in some cases like San Francisco we have
two screens now set up so those will
sell out as well so you might want to
get your tickets sooner rather than
later if we're not coming to your city
don't worry because the documentary is
still coming to your city you can just
go to minimalism film comm click on see
the film
and then you'll find there are several
hundred screenings already scheduled now
here's what we need we need your help
because many of those screens won't
actually happen unless we have enough
ticket reservations this isn't one of
those cases where you're like oh I'm
gonna wait to the day of the event and
then I'll just buy tickets that day no
you won't because then the screening
won't be happening we have to have
enough ticket reservations so we have
three or four thousand people who have
already gotten their tickets so far but
we need your help so if you have a
screening and you live in Wichita and
all of a sudden you say I'm gonna wait
the last day it will be too late if we
haven't tipped to the screening already
meaning we need to sell enough tickets
beforehand for the theater to actually
show the film so just go to minimalism
film comm and click on see the film you
can find your local screening grab your
tickets that way we can make sure the
the documentary actually plays in your
city you can also see the trailer for
the film there at minimalism film calm
let's listen to our first voicemail
question this one is from ascent Lee in
Montreal Canada five years ago I moved
to Canada for an indefinite amount of
time and before I left I got rid of 80%
of my things I'm talking about my car my
record collection my clothes and I just
kept two bins of clothes that were the
cream of the crop I mean I had been an
avid vintage shopper and all these
things are really special to me and
unique and like little treasures and the
plan was every time I came to visit from
Montreal I bring up DC and gradually
just fill it up and take all this stuff
with me well my mom threw it all the way
just threw it out and I was devastated
and it took years to forgive her it's
been five years and sometimes I still
feel myself longing for those items like
my identity was caught up in them and I
I just feel still like a really strong
attachment to it I just was wondering if
you have any advice for people who
involuntarily got their possessions
taken away or thrown out maybe a fire
maybe someone and how hard it is to let
go of the things
didn't have value to you that were
special that you felt were things that
you adored instead of like choosing to
give them up and I still have a really
hard time to this day with my wardrobe
because I feel like it doesn't represent
me those clothes did certainly I'm sorry
that you're dealing with some sort of
emotional stress and anxiety through
that whole process I will tell you I'm
glad that you did forgive your mother
it's important that we don't put things
over top of our relationships which I
did for a very long time I forsook the
important things for the material things
and I think you've realized that and
what you've probably realized I hope for
hope oh I hope that you've realized this
is that forgiving is freeing and by
letting go that's really giving letting
go is giving a gift to yourself and
being willing to let go of even the
things you thought were your favorite
things I know in a podcast episode prior
I talked about the experiment I did with
a journalist who said what are your
favorite things and I listed well here's
my favorite shirt and and here's my
favorite pair of jeans here my favorite
pair of shoes and I got to thinking well
why are these my favorite things and you
know what I realized was there are my
favorite things because I said there
were my favorite things not true that
shirt was very comfortable but it
certainly wasn't the only comfortable
shirt in the world it sure looked really
good on me but it's not the only shirt
that could ever look good on me
the truth was they were meaningful to me
only because I gave them meaning and the
problem with it as I was giving too much
meaning to those things and and then it
made me forsake the people around me and
so I'm reminded I read a study recently
from the Journal of consumer psychology
and and I'll just read a quick paragraph
from that the objects you struggled to
get rid of are likely tied to your
self-worth according to the 2011 study
rather than viewing those objects as
quote mine you may think of them as
quote me as they found that people
struggle the most
to part with possessions that lack
monetary or functional value that's why
people who lose their possessions to
burglaries or fires report the
psychological damage is far worse than
the financial loss yeah so Josh let me
ask you when you got rid of your
favorite pants and shirt and shoes what
happened man I my other clothes just
stepped up to perform their tasks guy I
had a a new favorite shirt that was
comfortable and looked good on me I had
a new favorite pair of jeans a new
favorite pair of shoes and and with that
experiment I realized that I could have
favorite things without tying too much
meaning to those things so for anyone
who's listening I would encourage you to
take a look at some of your favorite
things and just try to let go of one now
don't get rid of all of your favorite
things don't get rid of all of your
sentimental items in fact our
sentimental items are often the hardest
things to part with when when people
approach us and they're saying I'm
trying to embrace this minimalism thing
I'm starting I'm starting this
minimalist journey and I'm gonna start
with all my sentimental items I'm like
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa that that is
not where you want to start because you
want to get momentum and and it's really
hard to start with the sentimental stuff
because it's hard to let go of any of
that so so once you've reached a point
where you've gotten momentum then you
can start to tackle some of these these
sentimental items and with cently I
found that by by not associating them as
this Journal of consumer psychology
pointed out not associating those things
as me which is what you were doing
you're saying those were more me
basically we derive our self-worth from
those things I was able to say no those
are mine for a particular season and in
the long in the long run everything is
impermanent so you're not going to have
those things forever because even when
you die that they're going to go by the
wayside yeah she asked about you know
what happens with people who have a fire
in their home or maybe they get robbed
that they have a robbery happen and I'll
tell you certainly we've had many many
people come up to us at our events
and say oh I just had a fire or my
friend just had a fire or we believe got
robbed and and they took all of our
stuff and I I never realized how much I
wouldn't miss that stuff and usually
what Josh and I will say is
congratulations we'll put a spin on it
and say congratulations you have the
opportunity to start fresh now this is a
little bit different of a situation
because you know her mom threw him out
without her permission it would be like
you know if I was living with my parents
and they when I was you know away one
day they just went in my room and threw
everything out like that would feel very
disrespectful I think that would hurt me
worse then a fire or even someone
robbing me because it's like well I know
you why didn't you ask me and so maybe
there was a little bit of a
miscommunication there but I would say
suddenly this is an opportunity for you
to start over I I was thinking about
Josh and i's initial drive through
montana went when we first average drove
through the state we were coming back
from Vancouver BC and I just remember
when we first pulled into Montana I was
like oh my god this is the most
beautiful beautiful scenery I have ever
I've ever seen and then we drive 10 20
50 miles and then it was a completely
new landscape that was just as beautiful
maybe a little bit more beautiful maybe
a little bit less beautiful but I mean
really I couldn't tell you it made it
made me feel the same way and that's how
I kind of look at these clothes it's yes
you may have had the cream of the crop
you may have had all these wonderful
clothes that look great on you but that
doesn't mean that you can't go out and
find things that are gonna look just as
beautiful or maybe even more beautiful
yeah so congratulations
you had the cream of the crop there are
plenty more crops out there for you to
to gather that cream and have new
favorite things in your life and as you
move forward as you grow you'll find
that the things that you let go of
aren't as good as the things you're
running toward in the future yeah and I
think I would just add one piece of
advice to any listener is that if you
have something that you absol
love so incent least case she had these
two bins of clothes that were the cream
of the cop crop that she absolutely
loved if you're going to ask a family
member to hold on to them for five years
or let's say you're gonna put them in a
in a storage unit god forbid but let's
say you're gonna do something like that
make sure that you're very deliberate
with storing those so if you're gonna
storm with a friend or a family member
be very clear these are my favorite
clothes let me know if you're gonna get
rid of them if you're gonna put them in
a storage unit make sure you're gonna
put them somewhere that they're not
going to be damaged so I think a little
bit of ahead if you're going to store
some of your favorite items somewhere
please don't get a storage unit though
please amen
daiva and Denver has a question for us
what do you do with heirloom jewelry so
that was my grandmother's both my
grandmother's my mom held onto for me
and now I have it and it doesn't take up
a lot of space and I really don't mind
storing it I just know I'll never wear
it and now my six-year-old daughter
looks at it and she gets excited and she
wants me to hang on to it for her and I
really just don't want to burden her
with passing things on that she might
like now but she may not like later the
thing I do with my grandmother's jewelry
is I wear it all the time I mean these
four earrings I'm wearing right now
you look gorgeous thank you thank you I
well they just have so much sentimental
value to me no I totally respect where
you're coming from because then you're
actually at a at a great place right now
you have the opportunity to let go
because you don't really have this
emotional attachment to the stuff what
you have the attachment to is the
meaning you think other people may give
to it in some hypothetical future and
and in particular your six-year-old
daughter and what I would encourage you
to do is let your six-year-old daughter
play with it let her have have the
opportunity to use it now now she may
lose some of it she may get some value
from it now but like you said you don't
wanna burden her in the future have an
open conversation with her and make sure
that it's not burden
her as she gets older and if she if it
does then encourage her and help her let
go help her find someone else to give
value from it also when passing it on I
would encourage you to have fewer
sentimental items to pass on so it's not
about having no sentimental items or
filling your life with with $0.00 the
sentiment you what you want to do is
have fewer so the the fewer sentimental
items that you do have add much more
value to your life and to the other
people around you instead of watering
down your sentimental possessions by
having dozens or hundreds or thousands
of sentimental items yeah I would echo
the give give a one of the items to your
daughter I mean this could be a really
good learning experience for her whether
she hangs on to that one item and she
really values that and has that growing
up or maybe she does lose it I know when
I was like four or five years old my mom
gave me a watch it was like this little
you know cheap Casio digital watch but
it meant so much to me and I remember
losing it and I was thinking to myself
man that was my first watch I can't
believe I lost that I was really hoping
to hold on to that it was a huge
learning lesson for me when I got things
in the future I took better care of it I
learned a lot from it so I mean your
daughter six years old what a great time
to start helping her think a little bit
differently when she approaches things
like sentimental items our next question
is from Melissa in Pennsylvania I hear
does a lot of things from family and I
just feel a need to get rid of some
things that I'm really attached to the
stuff the stuff of course so I'm just
trying to figure out how to let go of
some of these things like have lots of
little tchotchkes and dishes and all
kinds of stuff how do I show of it and
also I think that these things are worth
something obviously and I want to sell
them on eBay or Craigslist or something
like that if I decide to get rid of them
and my husband says no that takes
energy and time so maybe you shouldn't
do that so anyway this is a hard one for
me I'm able to clear out a lot of things
that just don't really appeal to me
anymore but the things that have
sentiments attached to them are really
hard for me
well tchotchke by definition is is kind
of a pejorative I understand that we
have you know t-shirts or a little beer
koozie or something that may have a
little bit of meaning because we got we
got it out of at a time that we want to
remember but at the end of the day as we
always say the memory are not in our
things and what I would encourage you to
do is maybe pick a tchotchke Melissa
that you feel like you might be able to
part with and just put it in the trash
see how you feel the next morning that's
what I did I started really really small
I I never had a whole lot of sentimental
items um I had a shoebox full of like
letters and some high school memorabilia
after my packing party that I ran into
that was really really hard to let go
but that's that's kind of how I started
I just I picked the letter and I thought
to myself all right I'm gonna least let
one of these letters go I'm going to do
my best at this minimalism thing and I
took a picture of it so I could still
read it if I really wanted to my threw
it in the trash and the next morning I
didn't even think about I didn't in fact
I didn't even think about it until I got
home from work that day that next day
and that really taught me a valuable
lesson so that day I actually went and
grabbed that shoebox and took some
pictures of some of the other letters
that I wanted to hold on to and through
everything how I'll tell you what's
what's crazy though out of you know
probably 10 15 letters I might have
taken a picture of like two or three of
them because at the time when those
letters were written to me from family
members or friends or whatever they were
very meaningful but they weren't
meaningful once I read them again and
yeah I mean really I'm just boiling it
down to this Melissa
start small pick something that you feel
like you can start to get rid of and
really under get a feel for and
understand how when you let go of these
tchotchkes when you let go of a little
bit of China that it's not really that
they give a deal and it's not going to
hurt as bad as you think it will
certainly take a picture of that stuff
pictures can spark memories but the
physical item itself again the memories
are not in those items yeah I would also
give yourself a deadline you said you
think some of these things are worth
money you know what they may or may not
be worth money and your husband's like
no just hurry up and get rid of it great
you have someone who's there encouraging
you so set a deadline if I can't sell it
in two weeks then I promise that I will
donate it and and stick to that deadline
no matter what and try to solve the
things that you know you can get money
from you can do some quick research on
ebay or craigslist or wherever and put
in the work put in the effort to be
willing to let go and then when it comes
time to letting go especially of the
sentimental items be willing to let go
back in 2008 my mom moved from Ohio down
to Florida to finally retire and a few
months after she did she found out she
had lung cancer and then later on that
next year in 2009 she was gone and I
spent a lot of time with her down in
Florida she struggled through her her
chemo and radiation treatments but when
she passed I realized I needed to make
one last visit down to Florida and this
time it was to deal with her stuff so I
flew from Dayton Ohio down to st. Pete
Beach Florida and when I got to her home
I discovered about three apartments
worth of stuff crammed into her tiny
one-bedroom apartment and I'm not saying
that mom was a hoarder there were no
dead cats in her freezer but she owned a
lot of stuff she had 65 years worth of
accumulations and I'm not sure if you
know this but the average American
household has more than 300 thousand
items in it three hundred thousand items
but of course most of us aren't hoarders
right we just hold onto a lot of stuff
we hold on to a lifetime of memories and
I know that's what mom certainly did
the tchotchkes in there and a lot of
other things that she gave a lot of
meaning to and that by by proxy I was
giving a lot of meaning to and I had
really no idea what to do and so I did
what any good some would do
I called u-haul I called and I asked for
the largest truck they had in fact I
needed one so large I had to wait for an
extra day for the 26 foot truck to
arrive and as I waited for it to arrive
I invited someone mom's friends over to
help me go through sort through some of
her belongings there was just too much
stuff to go at it alone
I looked at her living room it was
stuffed with big antique furniture and
old paintings and more doilies than I
could count and then I walked over to
her kitchen our kitchen was stuffed with
hundreds of plates and cups and bowls
and ill-assorted utensils her bathroom
was stuffed with well with enough
hygiene products to start a small beauty
supply business and man I walked over to
she had this little linen closet and it
looked like someone was running a hotel
out of that linen closet which was
stuffed with just stacks of mismatched
bath towels and dish towels and beach
towels and bed sheets and blankets and
quilts and then I walked over to her
bedroom and don't even get me started on
her bedroom why did mom have 14 winter
coats stuffed in her bedroom calls it 14
now keep in mind she lived in st. Pete
Beach Florida suffice it to say mom
owned a lot of stuff I had no idea what
to do with any of it
so again I did what any good son would
do I rented a storage locker back in
Ohio so I could store all of mom's stuff
and when I called the storage facility I
asked him for the largest storage locker
they had you know what they asked me you
want one that's climate-controlled I
said climate control why would I won't
want it that's climate control is that
so mom's stuff can be comfortable no I
just want a big box
with a padlock on it you see I couldn't
commingle mom's stuff with my stuff I
already had a large house and a full
basement full of stuff but a storage
locker oh yeah a storage locker would
let me hold on to everything just in
case I needed it some day and some
non-existent hypothetical future you
know just in case just in case so the
three most dangerous words in English
language and so I was just sitting there
or standing there or boxing stuff but
attempting to finish packing mom's stuff
when I looked under her bed and I found
these four boxes and they were labeled
one two three four
these old printer paper boxes kind of
heavy sealed with a lot of packing tape
and so I pulled them out one by one and
I just sort of pondered from it I wonder
what could possibly be in those boxes
and then I realized it was my as I
opened the boxes and went through it was
my old elementary school paperwork
grades one through four and as I opened
the boxes my curiosity ran wild and I I
thought to myself why was mom holding on
to all this paperwork all this stupid
paperwork but then all these memories
came rushing back right and then it was
obvious mom was attempting to hold onto
a piece of me by holding on to all the
stuff she was holding on to all the
memories that were inside those boxes
but wait a minute mom hadn't accessed
those boxes in over two decades they had
been sitting there under her bed sealed
moving from one apartment to the next
she hadn't been accessing the memories
in those boxes which made me realize
something
important for the first time our
memories are not in our things our
memories are inside us you see mom
didn't either hold onto those boxes to
hold on to a piece of me I was never
inside those boxes but then I looked
around in her apartment I looked around
at all her stuff and I realized I was
getting ready to do the same thing
except instead of putting her memories
in a box under my bed I was going to
cram it all into a big box with a
padlock just in case so I did what any
good son would do I called you all I
cancelled the truck and I called and I
cancelled a storage locker and I
next 12 days selling or donating almost
everything and I learned a bunch of
really important lessons along the way
first not only that I learned that our
memories are not in our things but but I
also learned about value real value you
see if I'm honest with myself I was just
going to selfish it cling to Mom's stuff
but but but of course I wasn't going to
get any real value from those things as
they sat there locked away in perpetuity
but the truth is that by letting go I
could add value to other people's lives
just because I wasn't gonna get value
from Mom's stuff that doesn't mean that
someone else wouldn't so I donated much
of it to her friends a lot of them were
in the same building as her until local
charities and I gave the stuff a new
home
and the things that I was able to sell I
was able to take that money and donate
it to the to charities to help Mom with
her chemo and her radiation down there
in st. Petersburg and I realized that I
could contribute beyond myself if I was
willing to let go and when I finally
returned to Ohio I returned with just a
handful of sentimental items an old
painting a few bucks of photographs and
maybe even a couple doilies which led me
to another important lesson what's one
about sentimental items in particular I
discovered that by having fewer
sentimental items were able to enjoy the
ones we have much more I get far more
value from the few sentimental items I
kept than by watering them down with
unlimited numbers of tchotchkes and the
next lesson I learned was a pretty
practical one well it's true that our
memories are not in our things it's also
true that sometimes our things can
trigger memories so before I left for La
Florida I took a bunch of photos of many
of Mom's possessions before I donated
them and when I went back to Ohio I went
back with just a few boxes of
photographs which I was able to scan and
store digitally and those photographs
made it easier for me to let go because
I realized I wasn't letting go of any of
my memories and I think the last lesson
I learned was perhaps the most
compelling I learned that the true cost
of consumption is much higher than the
initial price tag you see but by
consuming all the stuff repeatedly
things that we're not using we actually
produce more waste and so being
responsible
the things we let go in donating them
finding the new homes it's the most
responsible least wasteful way of taking
things into our lives and letting go of
the things that no longer add value our
next question is from Sarah in Austin
Texas
my mom is I guess what you would call a
class a hoarder
and she keeps everything for example I
think she has every possible comforter
from our childhood and outfit that we
wore and pictures and she just doesn't
know how to let go which i think is even
harder now that her and my father pastor
separated within the last couple of
years and so she moved from a
four-bedroom house to a one-bedroom
apartment and I guess my question is how
do I help her kind of get rid of all
this stuff without being judgmental and
without being on you know unsupportive
of her and the anxiety that comes with
getting rid of the stuff
Sara first thing I would do is ask your
mother a few once helped because if she
doesn't want help then it's not help
it's not helpful at all and so if she
does want help and I would approach that
in a way that that's very kind and
supportive not telling her that she
needs to change but if she wants to make
some changes especially as she's gone
through a move that you're willing to to
help and I also would encourage you to
understand that we are all fighting our
own battles here and so what she's going
through at her age is going to be
considerably different from what you're
going through her willingness to let go
is going to be different her ability to
let go is going to be different and so
there's an essay that I would encourage
you to read it's on our website it's
about understanding other people in fact
it's called understanding others at the
minimalists comm slash understanding and
we sort of walk you through the process
there of what it takes to understand
what the person is going through and the
acronym we use is Terra ta R
a the first place we want to go is the
tea we want to be able to tolerate
someone in their behavior
someone we care about the first step
toward understanding is is tolerance but
of course tolerance is a weak virtue but
it is a good start
so first her her behavior might seem
bothersome to you and and I would say
that it's best for you to avoid a sort
of knee-jerk reaction of a
fight-or-flight like oh my god you
should live your life this way
well no her life is going to be
different and if she wants help the
first thing you can do is tolerate the
situation that she's in right now to
help her get to to the the next place
where you need to go and where she needs
to go after you've tolerated her her
behavior her belongings her process
that's a great first step
congratulations but then you want to be
able to accept where she is so that's
the second letter in the Tara acronym so
acceptance is is crucial I think to
truly live in concert with others we
must quickly move past tolerance toward
this feeling of true acceptance and so
once you've done that you realize that
your mother's collection has a purpose
to her or many of her things will still
have a purpose to you even though it
doesn't serve a purpose or bring you joy
individually and while you may not like
the particular thing that she likes
that's okay it's it's her stuff and
you're there you want to help so after
you moved on past acceptance you want to
move toward respect and this is this is
a big leap this is the are and Tara
you're going from accepting where she's
at to respecting her her things her her
love of of the things that she has and
and it's not just tolerating it's not
just accepting it's truly respecting her
idiosyncrasies and I'll tell you it's
much more challenging to to respect
where someone is than to just tolerate
them but once we're able to respect them
we're able to to start to figure out how
they tick and sort of get inside their
mind
and realize why you know okay maybe you
never hoard figurines or guitars or
whatever but there are many beliefs that
you also hold that other people may not
necessarily understand or may not be in
align with their their own beliefs and
and so if you extend the same respect
that you expect others to extend to you
you'll finally be you know one step
closer to the understanding and the
final letter in that Tara acronym is
appreciate so we've moved from tolerance
to acceptance to respect to appreciating
the other person now this is this is
difficult you know with respect in in
your that's sitting in your rear view
mirror I think that understandings right
around the corner but but only once
we're able to appreciate so let's say
your mother experiences great joy from
from her collection or some of the
things she has that she doesn't want to
let go of well why would you want to
change that
and so if she doesn't necessarily want
help then it's not about forcing help on
her unless it is inflect inflicting pain
on her or the people around her and so
ultimately you want her to be happy
right and so if her some of her things
bring contentment to her life then and
yet if you truly care about her which
obviously sounds like you care a lot
about her then her things should sort of
bring you joy by by proxy and and
because I feel that that happiness is
contagious so if some of these things in
her life make her happy it's going to
rub off on you as well yeah that makes
me think about Mariah and I and how I
mean if I wasn't if I was single living
by myself I would probably have you know
8090 percent less stuff that is in my
apartment right now because mariah has
you know some books that she holds on to
and some some DVDs or you know our
closet it's pretty much Mariah's closet
she's got a lot of shoes but at the end
of the day none of that bothers me
because I do
except her and I do appreciate in an in
respect her and I think really once
people get that that tera acronym down
it really helps you support the other
person and I you know I've never went to
Mariah and asked her hey we why I take
that back
I have definitely asked her to get rid
of you know some items I've never told
her that she had to get rid of items you
need to get rid of this or you know this
is going to affect our relationship I've
never done that I have went to her and
said you know if this is an item that we
don't use a lot is it okay if I donate
this or give it away to someone and
sometimes she says yes and sometimes she
says no I want to hold on to that and
that's okay but we worked through that
but what I'll tell you is having that
approach Mariah gets rid of she gets rid
of stuff all the time and she's came to
me yesterday she's like oh man I need to
I need to go through some of my stuff
and getting get rid of some of my items
do I feel that way sure but like I don't
bring that up to her all the time that's
something that she comes up with on her
own and it's really about you know
helping helping your grandmother see the
benefits if you really want to help her
move forward try to find some benefits
that she is going to experience from
letting go of that hoard whether it's
man you know if we get rid of some of
this stuff this is really gonna take a
lot of pressure off of kids and
grandkids to to not hold onto stuff or
maeín grandma you know I know that you
wanted to start that college fund for a
little Jimmy
if you sell that grand piano in your
dining room you might be able to start a
nice little college fund for Jimmy I'm
just throwing stuff out there but but
try to find the benefits that that she
can kind of look forward to but but
ultimately I will go back to what Josh
opened up this this answer with does she
want the help and that's really where
you got to start and if she does then
help her find the benefits yeah and if
she doesn't want the help and you still
want to set a good example for her
eventually she may come around and and
ask for that help in time I know Ryan I
have found that with a lot of people is
we don't go telling people you should go
clean out your closet or whatever
we set a good example and then often
people come to us for help after they
realize that they that they feel like
they need it people will ask you for
help when they are ready not when you
already our next question is from
Treasurer in Houston how do you prevent
yourself from having the sentimental
connection with your items especially
the new items you purchase this is a
problem I have and I'm trying to let go
but I do have a few new items that I buy
and I am so connected them already and
if I don't cut this out I'll be back at
where I was before and I don't want that
the first thing I do treasure is try to
bring fewer things into your life that
you can give attachment to so but by
clearing the clutter before it is
clutter that that's the best way to do
it we want to kill Godzilla when he is a
egg or a baby
don't wait till Godzilla is taking over
the town but once you do have a new item
how do you how do you prevent yourself
from attaching too much meaning to it
well I talked about the the journal
article from earlier but I I would
encourage you to realize that the thing
is not you it is a separate thing that
is there to augment your reality so to
speak to augment your experience with
reality these are just tools that you've
brought into your life and so ask
yourself a few questions yeah how could
I bring fewer things into my life and
then once you do why are you bringing
them into your life what is your outcome
it is your job at this point to
determine what is your outcome what
purpose is that the new possession going
to serve and that is why you have the
thing if it's going to bring you joy if
it's going to to serve a purpose in your
life that's why you you've brought the
thing in it's not it has no more meaning
other than the that it's a tool for you
to use to improve your life and your
circumstance yeah I would encourage you
I would just echo that do not bring in
as much stuff in your life I mean
thinking about this I'm trying to think
of an analogy
that we can kind of move away from stuff
and the only thing I can think of is
like someone who drinks a lot like a
really hardcore alcoholic who has worked
their whole life maybe not to stop
drinking but maybe to just be moderate
with their drinking so let's say they've
spent a year two years or however much
time they spent and they finally got to
this point where they were able to
consume you know a couple drinks a week
whatever it may be and then they have an
opportunity to go to like a party or
something and they know that they've
worked the past two years to really
control their drinking and they know
that if they go to a party this is gonna
be a trigger for them so in that case I
would suggest to that person like don't
go and trigger yourself to fall back
into what you've worked so hard to get
out of so I don't know I don't know if
that comparison makes sense or not to
all you listeners out there but I would
just say I mean it sounds like you had a
treasure I would say it sounds like you
had a hoarding problem or maybe hanging
onto possessions collecting putting
sentimental attachment to these items
but it sounds like you were able to get
over it because you said you know I'm
buying new items I don't want to get
back to that spot where I was at so so
do everything you can possible to to not
get back to that spot this also this
reminds me of an essay we wrote about
the things that were prepared to walk
away from the minimalists calm slash
walk in that essay does a really good
job of just showing how Josh and I have
really been able to pretty much prepare
to walk away from anything not just our
sentimental items but even relationships
I mean at the end of the day I love Josh
and I expect us to be best friends for
the rest of our lives but if Josh
started oh I don't know what's that
became a cereal yeah let's say became a
serial killer or he started embezzling
or he started you know he started making
prophecies I mean whatever whatever it
is things that
the line with my values and beliefs I
would have to distance myself from Josh
because ultimately this is my life and I
am going to make the best decisions
possible for me and the people around me
so I would encourage you to read that
essay treasure that that would certainly
help you at least kind of understand
where Josh and I come from I just want
to say to all these voicemail questions
this is not but this is not a perfect
life Josh and I are not talking about
hey this is how you live a perfect life
and when we're not even talking about
how to live an easy life what Josh and I
talk about is is living a simple life so
you know our answers here it doesn't it
doesn't mean that you're gonna you know
listen to this podcast and and have this
magic bullet answer and everything's
gonna be easy all of a sudden it takes a
lot of work to get there it takes a lot
of dedication you could look at it as
mindfulness I mean it's something every
single day that you have to focus on
that you have to work on especially in a
situation with treasure where she it's
so easy for her to become sentimentally
attached I would say for treasure this
is something that every day she's going
to have to focus on I would I'd
recommend meditating a little bit help
yourself be a little a little bit more
mindful that way that could certainly
help now treasure I know it's weird that
I'm like recommending meditation to help
you not attach sentiment with new items
that you bring in to your home but you
know I would liken this with an impulse
and I'm a very impulsive person and
meditation is something that has really
really helped me to get control of my
impulses all right Jo we'd love to hear
what y'all have to say so if you have a
comment about sentimental items
including minimalism tips for how you
handle letting go of sentimental items
or bringing fewer sentimental items into
your life or maybe how you enjoy the
fewer sentimental items you do have then
leave us a voicemail at 4:06 two one
nine seven eight three nine will air our
favorite comments and tips on the next
episode or on upcoming episodes and if
your voicemail is selected we'll send
you an autographed copy of one of our
books either essential or minimalism
live a meaningful life or of course my
personal favorite everything that
remains all right let's move on to our
iTunes comments of the week this one is
titled balanced and it was submitted by
rockwell rockwell writes I love that
Josh and Ryan know how to balance
radical straight talk with a gentle
loving understanding for the struggles
of the modern human condition listening
to this is one of the best hours of my
week Wow Rick well thank you so much for
that great comment we are so happy that
we could be one of the best hours of
your week yeah we're gonna send you a
copy of everything that remains I hope
you find some value in that and thank
you to everyone else who has left us a
review on iTunes
you're positive honest reviews helped
our simple living message reach many
many many more ears so please keep them
coming and we'll keep reading some of
our favorite iTunes comments on the
podcast so feel free to get creative
with all of your iTunes comments we're
looking forward to sharing some funny
comments in in the coming weeks all
right now it is time for our hashtag ask
the minimalists lightning-round we're on
Twitter and Instagram at the minimalists
and facebook.com slash the minimalists
all right our first question from the
social media world for hashtag ask the
minimalists lightning round comes from
Haley Haley writes how do I help my
parents get rid of sentimental items and
not just by giving them to me I've
already come clean and told them I don't
want my grandmother's China my
grandfathers coin collection etc but in
telling them this I believe it has made
them feel as if the burden of these
things is on them they are reluctant to
let them go because they feel guilty
Haley your job here is to give
encouragement to your parents because
ultimately it's not about forcing them
to get rid of the stuff you can set the
expectation that you don't want
the stuff but you can give encouragement
to help them let go at the same time ask
them for encouragement let them know
that you don't want to acquire these
these things or maybe you want to you
want to acquire only a few of the things
that will help you out now I'll point
this out this is gonna happen more and
more and more as as the years progress
us news reports them by 2030 the the
population of people over a 65 will
increase by 80% that's the whole baby
boomer generation right both of my
parents were actually a part of the the
Silent Generation kind of skipped the
baby boomer generation they had me late
in life and and so this whole baby
boomer generation that is coming of age
and many of them are turning 70 this
year you know they're looking to let go
and this is going to happen more and
more and more as you see over the next
15 years this population is exploding
it's one might say booming and and so as
these baby boomers age there's going to
be more of this wanting to hand off
sentimental items to two more people and
the best thing that you can do is
encourage them to let go now and let
them know that if they're holding on to
these things for the rest of their lives
it's something that you're going to have
to deal with
once they pass and generally parents
don't want to burden their children with
hundreds of thousands of items that
they're one day going to have to deal
with yeah and there's a part of her
comment where she talks about how you
know she feels as if the burden of these
things is on them now and I would say it
is on them right now because they're
making it a burden on themselves
I mean if josh came to me and said hey
man i've got this like record collection
that's really it's a really awesome
vinyl collection and i want you to have
it i'm gonna look at him and say i'm
sorry man i have no need for that vinyl
collection now josh might feel oh man I
really thought Ryan would
like this but he doesn't and now I've
got to hold on to this record collection
I would say that that record collection
is still a burden on him but what I
could do is is help him to move past
this burden that he's carrying why are
your parents feeling guilty start with
that question why do they feel guilty on
letting this stuff go if it's because
they're not gonna be able to pass it
down to you well there's a pretty easy
solution there right you explain to them
how you don't want this stuff passed
down to you let's say that you've got
other siblings and family members who
they want to pass these items to well
then get with those other siblings of
family members and see what items they
want to hold on to and and maybe they
can take those off of your parents hands
and then everything else that's left
over you can kind of help them maybe do
a packing party or or sell some stuff on
on Craigslist or Ebay I know one of our
voicemail questions they were asking
about selling stuff I mean that's
certainly a good option you don't want
to nickel and dime yourself to death it
gets really stressful when you're trying
to sell stuff for 10 20 bucks and you've
got a thousand items you're trying to
sell for you know a dollar here or five
dollars there three dollars three
dollars there I mean have a garage sale
you could do something like that too
let's so let those things go really
quickly but ultimately yes I would agree
with you the burden is on them now and I
would look at it as a an opportunity for
you to help release that burden so start
with a question of you know mom dad why
do you feel guilty about letting this
stuff go and and try to work it out from
there and with Ryan's analogy on the
record collection you know yeah I may
want to try to pawn this off on him
because I feel like he's gonna get value
from it and then I may get my feelings
hurt if I realize oh he actually isn't
but you know would hurt my feelings more
if he accepted it but didn't actually
want it because doing that is
disingenuous a great point and I feel I
feel that just by passing this on to him
I thought he was gonna get value from it
he wasn't and if you were to help me
find someone else that will get value
from it by either selling it or donating
it somewhere responsibly then I think
we're all going to win that takes a
little bit more effort
but that effort for the people we care
about is certainly worth it yeah I
certainly wouldn't want Josh to take
anything of mine out of guilt for sure
okay let's move on to our next question
comes from Rachel she asked what are
your thoughts on keeping sentimental
items for the purpose of passing them on
to future kids or grandkids you know I
think first off holding on to something
just for the sake of holding on to it is
wasteful III think that our material
possessions are material things they've
traveled a long way to get where they
are right now and if that is just your
attic or your basement or your closet
then you know someone initially gave it
to you or made it for you
or or manufactured it for a reason this
thing was supposed to serve a purpose at
some point in time and the manufacturers
or the gift giver or the person who had
the sentimental item you know the the
thing is is no longer doing what the
thing was supposed to do if it's just
being held on to sort of selfishly
clinging as I was getting ready to do
with all of my mother's stuff and so I
would encourage you to yes hold on to
some sentimental things that you think
you can pass on that other people may
get value from but be very very
selective about that and also be willing
to let those go those things that you're
holding on to treat them as if they are
no longer yours and if the other person
isn't gonna get value from it be willing
to let that go and instead of sharing
sentimental items with future
generations I would encourage you to
create sentimental experiences for them
and and the things I remember about my
mother and spending time with her as a
kid or even when she was she was dying
I remember the experiences none of the
things that she passed on to me yeah I
would I would just say I don't push
sentimental items on on anyone else I
mean that would be that's just kind of a
recipe for getting
feeling sir if you're holding on to a
let's say old pocket watch or something
like oh I'm gonna give this to my
daughter in 20 years and then you give
it to them and they're you know they
just kind of look at it like oh great a
pocket watch and it doesn't mean as much
to them I mean you're totally setting
yourself up to to kind of get your
feelings hurt so yeah I would say if you
have if you have items that you think
are going to add value or bring a family
member joy down the road and you want to
pass the sentiment on great but don't
push that item on the other person and
be willing to let that item go yeah
sentimental items are heavy they are
anchors they weigh us down and and if
you don't want to wait other people down
because you care about them then be
really careful about what you're holding
on to for them in the future all right
let's move on to Ed's question Edie
writes how do you have a conversation
about your items that someone else is
sentimental about but those items offer
you no value or enjoyment and only you
get to live your life these other people
aren't living your life for you and I
would just tell you that there is joy on
the other side of letting go and you
should never feel guilty about feeling
that joy that you experienced from
letting go yeah I don't know who's
telling you to hold on to your stuff if
it's an item that someone else feels
really sentimental about and you're
holding on to it specifically for them
just give it to them if you don't if you
don't have any joy from that item if
it's not serving a purpose and you are
literally holding on to it only because
someone else is asking you to hold on to
it then I would give it to that person
okay let's move on to Amanda's question
Amanda writes I have a lot of journals
that I've poured my heart into I can't
bring myself to throw them away I don't
never read them but I can't bring myself
to get rid of them what are your
thoughts well the first thing I would do
is consider having a scanning party we
always talk about this for our
photographs but one of the things that I
did was scan a lot of pages that I felt
like they were they were meaningful to
me and much like Amanda no I don't go
back and really reference them but I
know they're there I don't have any
space that's taken up with them they're
all sort of stored in the cloud and or
organized that way so that I don't have
to deal with it it's it is safely secure
if I ever want it but but I don't have
to have the material journals to move
along with me and and you know I'm I'm a
writer I'm looking at a journal right
now that I'm that I'm writing and I'm
holding it up in fact all of these these
questions here and one day I will get
rid of this I'll scan the stuff that I
need to scan but I'm also reminded of
Ernest Hemingway
you know his his wife lost a lot of his
notebooks they're actually stolen from
her and and that allowed him to move on
and create something new if we're always
holding on to our past creations
sometimes that those end up being a
roadblock to delving into something more
meaningful something different something
a new work that you'll be even more
proud of in the future yeah I would
encourage you to to go back and read
some of your journal entries see how
they make you feel because what what
you're thinking about is well all my
life is in these journals and I'm gonna
I'm gonna let go of me
but at the end of the day are you really
gonna get value out of those writings
you never read them we'll go back and
read them see how it makes you feel and
if you read them and you get elated and
you're like oh man I just remember this
time then great have a scanning party
and scan some of those pages but if you
read them like I know for me when I go
back and read college notes or journal
entries or the letters that I was
talking about early earlier from high
school they don't give me the same
feeling that they did at the time and
really it's kind of a relief for me
because it kind of helps me move on it
helps me to realize that I'm in a
different place in my life and that it's
it's time for me to make some new
experiences but in addition to having
I know Jim Morrison from The Doors he
talks about how he experienced the most
growth when he threw away his journals
so right before they blew up he had all
these journals with writings and songs
and all of this stuff in there and it
was weighing him down and he made the
decisions just to just get rid of it all
and he experienced the most the most
growth I mean we all know who the doors
are so there's a couple examples for you
hope that helps you out Amanda thanks
for the question okay let's move on to
Melanie Melanie writes how do you sort
your photos digitally so they are easy
to find later I have thousands and it's
taking forever
yeah if you have thousands of photos it
certainly will take a long time let's
find a way to make it more fun first off
so I just talked about the scanning
party let me expand on that a little bit
you can find the scanner I use also the
digital picture frame that I use over at
the minimalists comm slash scanning and
with the scanning party it's pretty
simple you invite some friends over you
grab all these photographs you have
either already scanned or you're getting
ready to scan and you go go through them
with your friends and it allows you to
recollect these memories and share that
experience with other people instead of
just doing this by yourself so you
invite some friends family whomever over
and you're actually able to scan the
things in that you want to hold on to
and you'll find there are so many photos
you don't want to hold on to at all so
you can you can just shred those you can
delete them if they're already stored on
on a hard drive now in terms of your
question Melanie
as far as sorting them I can tell you
what I do and I don't know whether or
not this will work for you but I named
each file after the people who are in
the the photo itself so if it's me and
Ryan and Sean Sean's here with us right
now recording the podcast for us I would
just name it
Ryan Sean and me or actually quite often
I use last names so I'll say Nicodemus
Harding and and myself and and then I
will put a year there if I know the year
and and that's it it's not not the most
eloquent way to do it but a lot
me to search for photos of different
people so if I have one with my mother
in it I'll just type in mom that's in
the photo folder and I'll be able to
find that if I want to find mom in the
year it's all catalogued that way as
well so just name the JPEG after the
people who are in the photo and maybe
even you want to add a location or you
want to add the year I would add that
right into the the title of the JPEG but
I would definitely definitely encourage
you to have a scanning party get a
digital scanner and and get some digital
picture frames and actually use those
photos that you have not been using for
so long
great um let's move on to Sarah's
comment or question I should say I don't
own that much stuff but I love Christmas
and I have way too many decorations what
are your thoughts on holiday decor Sarah
I think you have way too many
decorations do you know why because you
said you have way too many decorations
now if you would have said I have just
enough decorations I will tell you that
you probably have just enough
decorations and you know what that's a
moving target as well I for the longest
time had no Christmas decorations at all
but now the I'm with with Becca and Ella
like we put up some Christmas
decorations and that's awesome and will
that change over time yeah we may
acquire more we may let go of others and
what what I do is I enjoy access to to
decorations what does that mean well
that means that well I have some for our
Christmas tree and those are certainly
just for win items we talked about that
on the previous podcast on I think it
was episode number 9 having just for win
items which is different from just in
case so you can go back and listen to
that if you like but basically I know
that there are some things I'm going to
use only once a year Christmas
decorations are a great example I try to
keep those two having as few as possible
and then I enjoy access to other
Christmas decorations as well generally
if you live in a town that has some sort
of public square or public lighting or a
you know festival lights you you have
the opportunity to still experience
those decorations really elaborate
is also love driving around looking at
some of the crazy yard work and the
Santa's like making out with Santa Claus
or something on someone's front yard
with a billion lights in their yard you
can enjoy access to those things without
actually having to hold on to a infinite
number of holiday decorations Mariah and
I have no Christmas decorations right
now that's what we did last season we
just kind of went around and admired
other people's decorations but I will
say in the midst of doing that Mariah's
like man maybe we should get some some
holiday decorations next year and I'm
totally open to that and we'll talk
about that next year but certainly we're
not gonna go crazy with it will be very
very deliberate with it maybe we'll put
up a tree string some lights around it
maybe string some lights around the
house if that's what we want to do but
yeah we certainly wouldn't just go out
and start buying all of the on sale
Christmas item decorations just for the
sake of having them the last thing I
would add this is really for all of our
questions here is there's another
question to ask yourself when you're
thinking about letting go of sentimental
items and it's sort of a double question
that question is what's the worst thing
that could happen and Ryan and I wrote
an essay about this it is in our book
essential so I'm going to send everyone
who asked us a question today a copy of
an autographed copy of essential which
we talked a lot about letting go
especially in the first two chapters of
that book but here is an excerpt from
that essay this is the worst thing that
could happen risk scares the crap out of
people many of us associate risk with
failure failure with pain yet we're told
that we must take plenty of risks to
succeed thus success must be painful
right not necessarily when it comes to
challenging our preconceived notions
about risk the common platitude no
question tossed around by kind-hearted
friends and self-help gurus is what's
the worst thing that could happen
truth be told some risks are fairly
benign letting go of most of your
material possessions asking a cute guy
girl for his or her phone number writing
the first page of the book you've always
wanted to write what's the worst thing
that could happen likely nothing at all
there is no real risk in these harmless
endeavors other risks however probably
should scare the [ __ ] out of you
skydiving purchasing a home quitting
your job what's the worst thing that
could happen some pretty awful [ __ ]
actually death debt and poverty
respectively that doesn't mean you
shouldn't take these risks it means you
should approach each risk with logic
reason and intuition peer over the edge
before taking your proverbial leap and
if it makes sense then leap because not
leaping can be a much bigger risk the
difference then between the benign risks
and the real risks is that the latter
possesses potentially life-altering
worst-case consequences while the former
virtually no threat at all when you
think about it though the benign risks
can also hold life-altering consequences
if you change the question what is the
best not the worst but the best thing
that could happen perhaps getting rid of
your excess stuff will free up time
money space and give you the much-needed
peace of mind that you've been waiting
for
perhaps that phone number will lead to a
fulfilling relationship perhaps writing
that first page will lead to a second
and then a third and so on until you're
staring at a best-seller any of these
outcomes would likely change your life
for the better
similarly the real risks can have
tremendous upsides jumping from a plane
could be the most exhilarating
experience of your life the first time
you've felt truly alive a new home might
be ideal for your family a place in
which you enjoy meaningful experiences
walking away from your career could be
the catalyst toward starting your own
business or a life of growth and
contribution it was both for us that
doesn't mean you should undertake any of
these risks either it just means we must
ask these two question
more frequently after all what's the
worst or the best thing that would
happen if we did so ask yourself that
question what's the worst thing that
could happen by letting go and then
conversely what's the best thing that
could happen by letting go okay it's
time for our added value portion of the
show this is where we each recommend
something that has added value to our
lives recently and since we're talking
about letting go and and trying to feel
lighter and freer and happier from that
letting go process I'm going to
recommend a particular podcast episode
our friend Rob Bell has a podcast called
the Rob cast and episode 22 of that
podcast which is about a year old now
it's called light heavy light and he
talks a lot about many of the things
that we talked about here about being
willing to let go about moving on to a
new time in your life without some of
the things be that material possessions
or relationships or careers or things
that were in the way before moving
through a period of light to a period of
where things are heavy and then going to
another period where it's light again
the lightness is but beneath this weight
of clutter that we've been holding on to
so we'll put a link to that as well as
all of the things we've mentioned in
today's show in the show notes over at
the minimalists comm slash podcast but I
encourage you to take a listen to that
it is not on iTunes right now it's an
older episode and so you'll have to find
it there on his website at Rob Bell com
yes I would well I'll preface this
before I make my recommendation this
past weekend
Big Sky Film Festival here in Missoula
and Missoula big sky documentary film
festival it's all documentaries um I
thought our movie what was there on
opening night Friday and I didn't went
and went amazing but I've watched
probably six or seven movies over the
weekend and I have found like this crazy
emotional rollercoaster with these
movies and it has really helped change
my perspective
ways and I think you know for someone
who is trying to get rid of sentimental
things a new perspective could certainly
help so go and attend a film festival
that is near your area it doesn't have
to be a documentary film festival that's
what seems to make me the most emotional
is when I hear these like real life
stories and see what people go through
but any Film Festival will do because
there are some really great quality
movies there definitely do some research
on what movies you're gonna see I didn't
just show up randomly at different
movies I was actually surprised that I
wanted to see so many of them this
weekend but they just had great synopsis
and sounded like it would be something
that help would help change my
perspective on different things and it
certainly has so if you want a rich
experience if you want a different
different perspective that's one way to
do it let's move on to our next segment
what we call right here right now this
is where we finally get to talk about
ourselves for once let's say we have a
few things going on right now every
Tuesday in February at 7:00 p.m. Eastern
Time we're doing a hashtag ask the
minimalist round lightening round live
on video on periscope and on Twitter you
can find all the details about that at
the minimalists comm slash tuesdays but
we're having a ton of fun doing this so
join us while you can I already
mentioned our tour but we really are
looking forward to seeing you there if
you're there in one of those cities if
not we really hope you grab tickets to
this documentary cannot wait to share
this documentary with you right now we
have all the United States information
up there at minimalism film calm details
coming this summer on Canada Australia
and hopefully some other overseas
distribution and then I'm teaching a
writing workshop in June so it's a
little ways off but you can go ahead and
register for that right now at how to
write better dot-org I taught one last
month and it was awesome I really really
enjoyed teaching it and so many people
got value from it I decided to do it
again so you can find all the details to
that as well as my longer writing course
and how to write better dot-org and i'm
going to be spending some time in
Florida next month in March
and part of that is at our new coffee
shop bandit Coffee Co down in st.
Petersburg and I'll be attending the
minimalist org meetup while I'm down
there so hopefully if you're in the area
that one is on March 9th and so I'll be
there March 9th through the 17th I don't
have any other events going on but I
always spend a lot of time at Bandit so
you can find me there sitting at a table
or maybe I'll hop behind the counter
make a pour-over for you if you're
around so stop on through if you get a
chance you can find all the details to
that as well as all of our other meetup
groups we have a hundred of them in 8
different countries at minimalist dot
org and if we don't have one close to
you we have an online city where you can
meet with open-minded like-minded people
who are going to be supportive on your
journey of decluttering or minimalism or
whatever it may be and the last thing I
will say is another month is right
around the corner what a perfect time
for the 30-day minimalism game you can
find all the details about that at the
minimalists comm slash game it's
completely free and at the end of it
it'll be completely clutter free once
you've gotten rid of a bunch of excess
stuff it's a great way to challenge
yourself and also some of the people
around you all right let's listen to
some voicemail comments from our
listeners from last episode my name is
Elizabeth and I am from Houston Texas I
was calling to leave a comment about
post clutter how clutter clearing has
just been such a value added to my life
and I tease it the more clutter I clear
the more clutter applying to clear hey
guys my name is Jacqui drasi wanted to
suggest something out to your readers
something that really helped me become a
minimalist and survivalist minimalist is
really changing my mindset the power out
of not having things really comes from
not wanting them so once I decided to
not want things then it didn't matter
that I couldn't have them so now when I
see
say the latest trendy handbag or latest
[ __ ] fashion oh my I don't want that
which gives me the power of the choice
instead of saying I can't have that
because of debt restrictions or clutter
restrictions and that has miraculously
kept me a minimalist for several years
now
hey Josh and Ryan my name is Rachel I'm
from Portland Oregon when I guess when
you're dealing with physical objects or
my life your interaction is sort of at
the level of the physical world like
you're using your senses to interpret
and I guess interact with the world
around you you can see with those
sentient senses or perceive with those
senses and what I found upon sort of I
guess controlling that part of my life
to the point where I wasn't thinking
about it anymore
was that yeah it's like you feel called
toward a passion but a lot of times
people say well find your passion and
that's so they and so the way that I
sort of came to understand that after a
lot of trial and error and a lot of sort
of pondering this is that actually what
lied sort of is the next step beyond the
physical was like my feelings and it
sounds kind of goofy but what I realized
was that my feelings weren't just there
to drive me crazy and drive those around
me crazy if my feelings are actually
sort of this amazing internal guided
system toward or away from my passion so
I sort of started really tuning in for
those feelings and actually it was like
if it felt good if it felt like it
warmed up my chest if it kind of gave me
like a positive excitement I was like
you guys look into that thing more so
just sort of listening to that internal
guidance system and not judging where it
took me was really instrumental and
my passion alright y'all that's it for
this episode if you have questions for
the minimalists give us a call 406 to 1
9 7 8 3 9 and if you leave here with
just one message we hope it's this love
people and use things because the
opposite never works thanks for
listening y'all we'll see you next time
every little thing you think that's me
every little thing you think that you
need every little thing that's just
feeding your green you know I bet that
you'll be fine without every little
feeling that you got a hand every little
thing that you got you gotta reach for
you got a grand oh I bet that you'll be
fine without me
you